It just exploded nationwide.
It was a cultural phenomenon.
What color is happier
than purple?
No color.
This is Barney, and
this is what he sounded like.
Barney stands for inclusion,
acceptance.
You should love everyone.
We all have Sheryl Leach
to thank for that.
As her beloved character
was heading into
the stratosphere,
people couldn't accept
that this was just a show.
And so, let the bashing begin.
Some of the rumors that I heard:
Barney hides drugs in his tail.
They were violent and explicit.
Death and dismemberment
of my family.
I love you, Barney!
They were gonna come and find me
and they were going to kill me.
Just the dark side
of this whole moment.
That must have
devastated Sheryl.
There was something larger
going on here.
I don't think you could ever
think somebody would
go and shoot someone.